(swishing and squeaking)
- [Girl's Voice] My name is Aly Clipper,
and I have Deutan Color Blindness.
(gentle percussion music)
When I first discovered
that I was color blind,
I was in Kindergarten
and my teacher noticed that
I was coloring the sky purple
and the grass was brown.
They didn't think that
girls could be color blind.
The most true color I can see is yellow.
All the rest, I have a
really hard time deciphering.
Definitely, it affects my daily life.
(upbeat percussion music)
I am extremely excited to
see color for the first time
and if it actually works.
We are going to the park.
I'm feeling super nervous right now.
There's that chance that they don't work.
But I'm very excited too.
So, we are...
finally opening up,
for the first time, my Enchroma glasses.
I'm just super excited.
(gentle inspiring music)
Everything's so much more colorful.
Like, these, like these flowers over here,
they're normally white when I
don't have these glasses on,
and now, they're like, like a yellow.
The sky is really blue. (giggling)
That's crazy.
And when I have the glasses on,
it's like, just super red.
When I don't have the glasses on,
like the leaves and the
flowers look really similar.
It's a very noticeable difference.
Everything is just so vivid.
I never thought that colors
could be so beautiful.
(upbeat, happy music)
(swishing and squeaking)